you know what happens today I'm I'm in
the house my house is like a shopping
mall right right the front door kids are
always running in and out so it's a
sudden after morning and the doorbell
goes it's one of them doorbells don't
stop you ring it it goes ding D ding D
fancy house but three days he going Who
the hell's at the door and we have these
Tour Vans come around the PE Hills they
just take tours at your house now is I
thinking it's some kids to see my kids
right and so I'm sitting there and
watching the television and oh what's
this now about kids go she a room's
upstairs on the left and they go this
guy's really cool man so all these kids
they're looking around my house
and really good got a tourist he let a
tours friends with our kids you
know sh do you get upset when Azie lets
tour buses of people into the house I'm
standing my
jacking my
ass